knight g5 of course i mean two losing
moves only
two legal losing moves that's amazing
actually it's very rare
only two losing moves yeah that's in the
position two losing moves
in general you have always a way to give
all your away all your pieces
i don't see how it can no no i think uh
he's moving around i mean
clearly
yes and also up on the clock now
yeah because as you said you understood
to the right
way to defend it
what would be the last time of the
champion ah no there's no last time
he says though his opponent says sure
two more games for the world champion
against izzy penco
he will be joined by mvl against
kayaking
and bakutov against fion
what's not to like while uh
vladimir putif won his stay back match
against vladimir ivic
dudabit i mean tabata by beat
matthew and
that's it and of course in the women's
section
um alamosa took one or match against
so let's see if we have some pairings
already in the open section
yeah okay back uh a bucket will be later
but so so let's see the pairing maybe
for the woman we saw it already